my name is maria i'm the owner
of the restaurant for 25 years
perfect so we know that uh casa don quan
sells a lot of delicious mexican food
in particular this week it's very
important we talk about
tradition and with that we're talking
about tamales so can you tell us a
little bit about the history of tamales
and where the tradition really
originated from
yeah as you know the tamales and mexican
this time
you can find everywhere on those fiestas
like navidad nuevo that's a very popular
plate
you know we you can find any kind and
any flavors
that's very good and we have the tamales
here
usually we make it like pour with the
red salsa
the green with the chicken and the
cheese with jalapenos
and also we have the sweeter ones with
our
raisins pineapple and cinnamon
so which ones are the most popular that
sell
i think a lot of people like like
chicken pork and cheese whatever
that's that's good all that's good so
for those who don't know about tamales
how do you make tamales uh you know the
tamales are really hard to walk a lot of
work
that's the reason the people doesn't
like to to do it
because that's a lot of preparation we
need to clean the leaves like the corn
leaves
to put it on and the the masa
we need to prepare with the lamb salt
salsa and everything and later you need
to prepare
like you put
whatever you want and that's a lot of
work
how long does it usually take to prepare
how long
how long oh my god that's a long time
like probably
taking like four hours if you want to
make it
tamales and in a little bit about just
tamales in general why is it so
important to have tamales during
christmas
why does the majority of the mexican
households they have tamales or they
celebrate with tamales yeah
i i think that's the tradition that's
that's the traditional and tell me a
little bit about
why is a little bit more important just
to have it during christmas or why does
it connect to the christmas
meaning at the moment and christmas why
is there a connection
i don't know i think that's the cool
thing
i remember when i was young like a child
i remember
all the time on this time that i'm
honest none another times
just and now and if you go to mexico you
you can eat tamales all the time
but before you eat tamales only on
christmas time
or major time i don't know why but
tradition and tell me here at casa don
juan
uh we talked about the you guys sell
tamales
are you guys seeing a business in
selling tamales this week
i usually not like like the
another year but
now that's like a really really slow
business
but you know the people when you want to
eat tamales who come in
and ask for them or take at home or
either the restaurant
i think the more hispanic people
do this tradition on this time